oh you have Bank this is fabulous
hi my name is Ricardo I'm the teen my
name is Mandi I'm a former teacher
getting back into the role today and I'm
going to grade your Instagram the only
thing I'm really nervous is about as if
she like goes down to like older pose
that I look like a fetus and that's just
embarrassing but other than that I'm
nervous that I'm gonna go and see that
you have like 7 million followers and
that your whole feeds garbage alright
let's get started I'm here ready mm-hmm
I guess I'll just give this to you okay
so is this your insta or your fin step a
fin stuff for those of you who don't
know is a fake Instagram where you
basically just post like the hood wrap
things you do things that are not
appropriate for the real insta let's
just do it let's stick to the r insta
the real instant today I'm so excited to
be roasted by my dear friend here
alright so first of all I like your name
okay thank you
Ricardo dot in between I think that's
cute
I like your quote go west young man go
west and grow up with the country
because I just moved here yeah he's been
in LA for two weeks so he followed that
sage advice the most recent we're going
with yes don't know if you heard but I
live in California and he's giving a
real mixed message of California because
we've got this very moody lighting here
I like the stripes in the back and your
stripes and your shirt I don't know if
that was love strength it was really
upsetting when I found out I couldn't
wear stripes here so who are you meeting
here it's as a dream come true
oh whoa election of photos yeah that's
my friend Rachel that's when I went to
the ariana grande concert so that one's
a little misleading yes because I got to
see her I was on the floor she's great
ten another ten highly recommend that
experience I think this is adorable not
thank you heard but he's graduating and
he's on the scooter and he's just
scooting right out of high school I love
it that's cute whoa check you out you're
so cute thank you
I will say that one pet peeve I have
with Instagram is all of the like fake
candid shots where people are looking
off into the distance oh yeah I did I
did set that up that was set up I don't
understand these gangsters are doing in
this construction site to be ferrets
from November of 2018 so maybe you've
matured those were different times
there's a different kind of matter cute
where were you know that was in Chicago
I go okay
the bow ties back the bow tie has been
making several comebacks the suspenders
are you batching your content we call it
I guess you two bunch at once and then
you don't have to think of something a
gross I get this one he went to Paris I
did go to Paris my junior year summer
break I believe please so you must not
post too much because I yeah right I
could get two feet off yeah you could
really okay he's laughing so we're gonna
we're gonna try in here look at that I
thought the duck face in like the hard
looks for me yeah cuz it was like frat
party theme okay I see you have a here's
about science offender collection soccer
your prom every picture that you've seen
has either been prom or a special event
I just feel like I look better with a
bowtie I feel like I look more
professional with a bowtie to be quite
honest I have to show this cute dog oh
that's Toby and he was clever he's
heading some photographer now I think I
was like 14
oh this is fabulous I think your friends
are gonna be angry with you but no
they're not to Florida and I don't want
to talk about it was a question I was a
Frenchman yeah that's like like actual
throwback I'm pleasantly surprised I
have little really oh my gosh that makes
me so happy yeah thank you
I honestly feel relieved because I
thought I was about to like get dragged
through the dirt but
I was also pleasantly surprised with her
reaction to my Instagram I think that
this is you know if Ricardo if you were
my son I would be proud for this to be
your Instagram I don't know if it's the
same for the Finn stuff but you know
there's nothing inappropriate nothing
just tasteful I didn't think it was that
bad I wasn't too worried about it but
like like I said it was like pre Phaedo
like when I had the bangs like not a
good era
yeh okay that's not bad I'm okay with
the big boys
[Music]